okay so if I would explain my work I
started back in 1962 working on the
touch general topic is how do prices
incorporate new information it's called
the efficient markets hypothesis but
that's it basically
how do prices incorporate new
information so I devised a lot of tests
to how you about how you go about doing
doing that that's one branch of asset
pricing for which the award was given
the other one is what we call asset
pricing models which are really stories
about how you measure risk and then what
is the relation between risk and
expected return so they are basically
risk return story so those are the kind
of the two main branches of of asset
pricing which I've been working on for
the last 53 years